Um,
you get points for that if you stay,
um,
which is of course a really good point.
You,
you have more abilities to get to a
solution.
But that is also like,
it's also assuming that you will always
get to a solution.
Yes,
true.
yes,
yes.
Spend a winning solution that will keep
them
true.
Well,
you know,
there used to be before the divorce laws
were really liberalized,
there were there you could sue for
irreconcilable differences and,
and sometimes people do find themselves
in that situation.
It's like one person wants children and
the other person doesn't like that's a
tough one.
It's a tough one to negotiate.
So I'm,
I'm certainly not saying that just
because you lock yourself into a,
like two cats in a barrel that,
that will make you solve your problems
because problems are hard to solve and
sometimes you can't solve them.
I was just pointing out what the cost
of,
of leaving the back door,
what the cost of leaving the back door
open ends.
And it's a big cost.
And,
you know,
one of the things that I see too is that
people's identities fragment
increasingly across time.
You know,
one of the things that you have as you
age is something like the continuity of
your life,
you know,
you,
you have someone that you're with,
you've tied your story together with
theirs,
you have children,
maybe they have children.
It's like there's this continual payoff,
so to speak,
in quality that you obtained from
staying within that frame.
And you can jump out of that.
And I suppose to some degree that that
provides freedom.
But it isn't obvious to me that it does
that for people
only that one specific relationship.
It's my email.
No,
but,
but it's also the case that sequential
relationships are unlikely to be that.
So look,
I,
I'm not,
I'm not make,
I'm definitely not making a utopian case
for marriage.
So
I would like to hear the case for the
voice from you because they think it's
really interesting.
Right?
It says top points,
but at the same time I think there are
relationships that are wanting.
Yup.
And we,
if that's the case,
then insistence on a can cannot be good.
Yeah,
well that's,
that's definitely the alternative
argument.
And of course there are strong things to
be said on both sides,
but see,
there's some,
there's some additional problems with
divorce that people don't really grasp
when they're young,
like the,
that you can be divorced once you have
children.
That's kind of a stupid idea because you
can't.
You can,
you can,
you can find a limited substitute for
your initial freedom.
But if you,
if you have kids and you try to get
divorced,
the probability that that's going to
demolish your life is a very,
very high.
First of all,
it's incredibly expensive.
So one or both of you is going to come
out of that poor and
your market value has declined.
Let's say you're the woman who takes the
kids.
Your market value has declined
radically.
You're going to be poorer.
The man,
he's just a screwed because he is now an
indentured servant and there's no escape
from it.
So it's.
And it's not so bad if you can negotiate
a peaceful separation and some people
can,
but lots of times if you have a terrible
relationship,
it's not like negotiating and peaceful
separation is all that easy,
but if you're at each other's throats,
good luck to you.
I think it's roughly equivalent to
having nonfatal cancer.
It is not pleasant.
It's a 10 year process.
Fifteen year process will cost you
$250,000
and it'll tear a big chunk out of your
life and also it will really disrupt
your relationship with your kids.
And you know,
you bring kids into a step.
Parent family,
they do not do as well.
Step parents are not as good as parents,
as biological parents.
And the data on that is clear.
Now obviously there are exceptions
because there are terrible biological
parents and there are wonderful step
parents,
but if you look in aggregate,
it's not that easy to care for children.
You need to everything.
You can binding you to them.
And if there's someone else's children,
mostly they get in the way of the person
that you love.
Right?
Well,
if I'm,
let's say you have a child,
I'll be right out.
Let's say you have a child and I want to
go out with you every second you spend
with that child is a second you don't
spend with me and,
and there's going to be a price for
that.
I'm not going to be happy about that.
And if I have a child,
you're going to feel exactly the same
way.
You might say,
well,
no,
I love children.
It's like,
yeah,
sure,
sure you do.
I doubt it.
You might love your child and,
and you know,
it's pretty specific the way that people
loved children.
So,
and the rate of abuse for kids in step
parent families is way higher than it is
in biological families.
There's not even any comparison.
So anyways.